si l'on s'en tient à ce que nous venons
nous venons d'entendre c'est-à-dire une
réorganisation de l'état-majoré surtout
de celui qui va conduire les opérations
dans un but de évidemment de
d'efficacité et de durcissement de la
position russe
c'est tout à fait possible mais il y a
un bémol c'est que grecymov
contrairement à son prédécesseur qui va
lui servir d'adjoint désormais sous
l'eau viking qui est un qui est en
quelque sorte un boucher il faut bien le
dire comme ça girassimov lui a une
certaine on va dire éthique et notamment
n'est pas prêt à sacrifier ses soldats
comme on l'a vu récemment justement
comme on le voit toujours à barkout par
grappe entière quitte à évidemment de en
faire de la chair à canon
je rappelle que en lors de la deuxième
guerre de Tchétchénie à napolitkovskaï
c'est-à-dire la journaliste qui a été
assassiné pour ces reportages sur cette
garantie et sur sa critique de la Russie
avait reconnu que guérismov avait en
quelque sorte quand même sauvé l'honneur
de l'armée russe puisqu'il avait
condamné il avait fait condamné un
soldat russe qui s'était livré à des
exactions qui avait violé des femmes et
égal à simov n'avait pas hésité donc à
faire punir ce soldat là où d'autres
évidemment aurait passé l'éponge donc
c'est vrai qu'il concentre tous les
moyens puisqu'il est chef d'état-major
de l'armée c'est vrai aussi que et on va
peut-être le voir à l'instant il est en
confrontation avec d'autres éléments de
cette Russie
occupante et concurrente et que ça lui
vaut en plus une proximité avec Vladimir
Poutine qui est quasiment sans pareil
voilà ces autres éléments ce sont les
hommes de Wagner cette force
paramilitaire qui a revendiqué cette
semaine la prise de solidaire alors ça a
été assez surprenant puisque Moscou le
Kremlin a contredit ses propos pourquoi
il y aura-t-il de l'eau dans le gaz
alors
d'abord il faut reconnaître que
prigurine le créateur de cette de cette
milice était un très proche de Poutine
il a même été le traiteur du Kremlin
puisqu'il préparait certains dîners et
puis alors il s'était il s'était
spécialisé dans cette chaîne alimentaire
si j'ose dire puisque il avait récupéré
l'alimentation des cantines des écoles
et aussi de l'armée alors là c'était pas
du même niveau que pour le Kremlin enfin
il avait cette filière et puis que
s'est-il passé brigo jeune a commencé à
faire partie comme
kadirof de Tchétchénie de ceux qui ont
critiqué petit à petit la conduite des
affaires dans cette armée non pas pour
dire qu'il s'agissait d'une guerre sans
but d'une guerre inique non pour dire
qu'elle n'était pas bien menée et
frigogine a dit la même chose que
catégorie ils ont dit nous on peut en
parler au président Poutine et vous
voyez bien il s'agissait pas de remettre
Poutine en cause il s'agissait de dire
vous n'allez pas c'est loin vous êtes
trop c'était donc l'idée c'est que
pigogine serait en train de se placer
éventuellement comme une alternative
aboutine non pas une alternative
raisonnable au sens de quelqu'un qui
aurait compris le le caractère
monstrueux de cette guerre non au
contraire quelqu'un qui dépasserait
Poutine par la droite si encore de la
place mais apparemment oui et qui donc
relancerait cette guerre au profit
évidemment de ses hommes mais aussi dans
l'idée d'une Russie qui ne céderait
absolument pas un pouce de terrain il y
a une inconnue quand même là-dessus et
vous avez eu raison de dire que
Wagner c'est propulsé en tant que tel
elle-même comme comme vainqueur de cette
bataille à soleda jusqu'à présent on
connaissait Wagner pour ces coups ses
coups de aide dans un putsch exaction
commise en Afrique en République
centrafricaine probablement au Mali mais
pas comme un groupe de 1500 à 4000
hommes capables d'affronter une armée
régulière celle de l'Ukraine dans des
dans des batailles d'artillerie ça ne
paraissait pas tout à fait être le cas
de Wagner donc avoir ce qui s'est passé
sur le terrain mais c'est probablement
la raison pour laquelle l'armée russe à
la fois parce qu'elle se sont vexées par
une éventuelle victoire et réussite de
Wagner et à la fois parce qu'elle défend
d'autres intérêts que ceux des
dirigeants de cette ministre privée